Minusgrade, Kälte und trotzdem warme
Sonnenstrahlen auf der Haut.
Der Winter in seiner weißen Pracht kann
durchaus idyllisch sein
und wird doch allzu oft unterschätzt.
Das behauptet jedenfalls sie:
Für Barbara Schaefer ist der Winter die
schönste Jahreszeit von allen.
Über ihre Liebe zu Eis und Schnee hat die
Berliner Autorin ein Buch geschrieben.
Was den Winter heraushebt, ist,
dass die Welt in so‘n komplett anderen
Zustand gerät.
Also Frühling und Herbst ist ja nur kälterer
und wärmerer Sommer, aber im Winter
gefriert Wasser und gefriert die Landschaft
und dadurch ist es komplett anders.
Eine Faszination, die nicht jeder
nachvollziehen kann – gerade in Metropolen
wie Berlin, wo sich die kalten Monate
meistens grau in grau präsentieren.
Der Winter macht traurig und das bekämpft
man nur,
wenn man zusammen mit Freunden
unterwegs ist.
Wenn Schnee wäre, wäre er noch schöner.
Aber irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck,
Schnee macht
gerade so‘n riesen großen Bogen um Berlin
herum.
Man muss gute Laune haben, dann macht es
… der graue Himmel nicht so viel aus.
Um sich die kalte Jahreszeit angenehmer zu
machen, gibt es einige Möglichkeiten.
Warme Getränke und Kerzenlicht sorgen für
Behaglichkeit.
Und wenn es draußen kalt und grau ist, laden
die eigenen vier Wände geradezu ein,
mit der Familie mehr Zeit zu verbringen und
es sich so richtig gemütlich zu machen.
Auch ein Wellnesstag lässt den Winter
kurzzeitig vergessen.
Man kann ihn natürlich von innen genießen,
wenn man‘s sich halt richtig schön gemütlich
macht zu Hause.
Wenn man jetzt im Winter im Schneematsch
draußen Fahrrad fährt,
ist es natürlich nicht so prickelnd.
Da hält sich dann meine Winterliebe auch in
Grenzen.
Wer doch lieber raus möchte, entkommt der
städtischen Wintertristesse
mit zahlreichen Aktivitäten in idyllischen
Schneelandschaften –
Wintersport in den Bergen oder die klare
frische Luft bei einem Ausflug im
Pferdeschlitten genießen.
All das reicht Barbara Schaefer nicht.
Sie reist dem Winter bis zum gefrorenen
Baikalsee in Sibirien hinterher
und sucht weltweit Gegenden auf, die sonst
nur wenige sehen und erleben:
Schneeschuhwandern durch einsame
Landschaften in Schweden
oder mit einem Hundeschlitten durch die
weißen Ebenen Grönlands gleiten.
Den Winter und die Kälte genießt sie nicht
zuletzt durch den Kontakt zu Einheimischen
die sich mit den Bedingungen vor Ort
arrangiert haben.
Ich hab tatsächlich festgestellt:
: Je weiter man in den Norden kommt, umso
mehr lieben die Leute tatsächlich den Winter.
Also da ist es nicht so, dass man dann schon
im November denkt
‘Oh Gott, jetzt wird es wieder schrecklich‘,
sondern die Leute freuen sich tatsächlich
stärker auf den Winter und sind eben auch
bei Dunkelheit viel draußen.
So wie in der norwegischen Stadt Tromsø.
Sechs Monate im Jahr liegt hier nördlich des
Polarkreises Schnee.
Und doch widerlegen die Bewohner das
Klischee,
die Polarnacht in Norwegens Norden würde
depressiv machen.
An der Universität Tromsø, der nördlichsten
Hochschule der Welt, forscht Joar Vittersø.
Er hat herausgefunden,
dass die Menschen hier auch ihre Einstellung
zum Winter zufrieden macht.
Im Norden Norwegens haben die Menschen
Wege gefunden, mit der
dunklen Jahreszeit umzugehen: mit
Aktivitäten,
auf die sie sich im Winter freuen und die sie
für die dunkle Jahreszeit entschädigen.
Die modernen Skier wurden in Norwegen
erfunden.
Und die Naturverbundenheit der Einwohner
von Kindesbeinen an
macht es ihnen außerdem leicht, mit Kälte
und Schnee umzugehen –
eine Angewohnheit, die man sich in anderen
kalten Gegenden durchaus abschauen kann.
Also ab nach draußen und den Kreislauf in
Schwung bringen.
Der Winter ist einfach Teil der Abfolge im Jahr
und wenn viele Monate Winter ist, dann
arrangiert man sich einfach sehr stark damit
und erfindet immer wieder Möglichkeiten,
damit umzugehen und das fand ich halt
selber auch insgesamt faszinierend.
Und wer dennoch keine Liebe
für den Winter empfinden kann,
dem bleibt nur eins:
die Vorfreude auf den Frühling.